To say all Hell had broken loose would be
a vast understatement.
A more realistic assessment of what had happened
in the aftermath of SCP-001, The Lock, being
opened, would be: Every Hell had broken loose,
along with every heaven, every anomaly, every
ancient god and buried horror, every nightmare
from outer space and from different dimensions.
Every agent of the apocalypse, every emissary
of Ragnarok, every entity - sentient and otherwise
- with a vested interest in seeing the world
as we know it come to an end.
So it goes without saying, the SCP Foundation
and their allies had their work cut out for
them.
So before we march once again into the terrifying
future, let’s quickly refresh our memories
as to how we got here.
The Lock had started off as a mere curio in
a 19th-century explorer’s vast collection,
before it fell into the possession of the
SCP Foundation, and became designated as SCP-001.
For years, The Lock perplexed people with
its seemingly limitless mysteries - From its
origins to its strange markings, to what would
happen when The Lock is finally opened.
And it would indeed be opened, in perhaps
the ultimate example of “Be careful what
you wish for.”
An entity known as The Harbinger invaded Site
10 and used a special key to finally open
The Lock, triggering the ultimate apocalypse.
Anomalies became more powerful and escaped
containment all over the world.
Animals mutated into giant monsters and began
causing chaos.
Mythological creatures such as the goddess
of SCP-1000, the mighty Norse Fenrir, and
an entity that transformed into a giant, evil
duck, went totally berserk.
The Lock itself completely blew up Site 10
- Before remaking it and its personnel elsewhere
- and turned the crater where Site 10 used
to be into an incredible, otherworldly valley
on Earth, where an even more incredible meeting
would soon take place.
SCP-990, The Dream Man, came to the Administrator
of the SCP Foundation and warned her of impending
doom.
But she decided that, no matter how dire things
got, The Foundation would fight back.
And that brings us to the star of the show:
SCP-343, also known as God, but please...Call
him Yahweh.
No point in sticking to formality here at
the end of it all, right?
Ever since The Lock was opened by that pesky,
mysterious Harbinger, he’d been an extremely
busy deity.
Last time, we saw him make his long-awaited
rendezvous with another SCP-001: The Gate
Guardian, whose true name was revealed to
be Uriel.
Yahweh instructed Uriel to open the Gate to
paradise, releasing his armies of powerful,
sword-wielding angels upon the earth.
And now we’re all caught up.
Let the madness commence.
After instructing Uriel to free his armies
and lead them in a war against evil, Yahweh
decided to address the most powerful humans
on earth, and enlist them in his fight.
Those same arrogant humans who foolishly believed
they’d been containing him all this time,
and not that he’d simply been choosing to
stay with them.
Perhaps now, they would see sense.
Yahweh manifested physically in thirteen different
places at once and spoke to the O5 Council.
They were filled with awe and holy terror
as the deity appeared before them like a glittering
ghost, eyes glowing, exuding pure power.
Speaking with absolute authority, he said:
“Uriel, my servant, once told your Founder
to prepare for the great and terrible day
of the Lord.
This day now approaches.
Make your final preparations.
There is nothing else you will need to do
but wait.
My armies ride across the Earth.
Soon I will call the Four Horsemen.
Once the last judgment has been unsealed,
then shall the great and terrible day of the
Lord come.
And then all will have Paradise.”
And with that, he was gone, leaving the most
powerful human beings on Earth shaken.
It was about time they got a reality check
about their true cosmic insignificance.
Still, the act of splitting himself thirteen
ways briefly gave Yahweh symptoms similar
to vertigo.
During his confinement, he hadn’t needed
to truly flex his power, and now he was finally
beginning to feel the limitations of this
human form.
But he didn’t have time to muse over the
nature of human frailty as the world he’d
worked so hard on began to crumble around
him.
He needed to return to the Valley, the precursor
to Eden’s return.
The Valley where only He had set foot.
He breathed a sigh and teleported there, prepared
to finally be alone and collect his thoughts…
But he wasn’t alone.
You’ve probably heard salacious stories
about parties getting out of hand.
It always goes the same way: A birthday party
or small gathering created as an event on
Facebook, but accidentally set to public.
Not long after, little Andrea’s quinceañera
or Joe’s Bar Mitzvah suddenly has 5000 attendees,
all strangers, and the riot police are called
in to get the chaos under control.
Now imagine that same thing, but instead of
rowdy drunkards, it’s cosmic figures and
apocalyptic beings from all over the multiverse.
And now you know what Yahweh walked in on.
Welcome to the Valley of Gods and Monsters.
It was crowded with beings that would boggle
your mind to even comprehend.
Deities with two limbs, six limbs, a hundred
limbs, or none.
Spirit whales and feathered snakes flew overhead,
with clouds of intelligent insects and fae
flying just below.
A giant furred creature moved over a distant
mountain, looking on.
A pure black humanoid entity appeared before
Yahweh, blinked, and then vanished.
Moments later, a giant centipede-like creature
skittered past him, giving him a nasty glare.
Everyone was here.
The pantheon of Greek Gods, from Zeus to Hades.
Every Egyptian God and Monster.
The bird-headed Ra, the Jackal-headed Anubis,
the monstrous snake-beast Apep.
The Norse Gods were drinking and having rowdy
conversations with the Hindu deities.
Entities so ancient their names have been
forgotten, and monsters whose faces had only
ever been seen in the restless dreams of billions
of humans, then quickly forgotten upon waking.
In short, “The gang’s all here!”
Yahweh, for the first time ever, was feeling
lost, confused, and even small.
He decided to mingle with a crowd of humanoid
Gods, wanting to be with people who looked
like him.
There, he met a dark-skinned woman with long
hair and lip piercings known as Asherah.
Although his memory of her was faint, she
reminded him that she was once his consort,
back before he made the admittedly jerk move
of wiping out all the other pantheons of history
so that he could rule over the cosmos alone.
But now, with the opening of The Lock, everyone
was back, ready to cause the apocalypse.
But here was the big problem: They didn’t
just want to cause the apocalypse, they wanted
to cause their apocalypse.
Every belief system had its own vision for
how this strange little show we called Earth
should end, and not all of them were compatible,
so a very heated debate was breaking out as
to who should really get to bring the world
to an end.
And the most darkly funny part of this?
Very few of these Gods, entities, and creatures
even knew about each other until a few moments
before, so the fact that they had this level
of competition was a very unpleasant surprise.
To put it into perspective, imagine you’re
Neil Armstrong, circa 1969, taking the Apollo
Eleven shuttle straight to the Moon.
The craft lands, he’s suited up, preparing
for the first-ever moonwalk - his iconic quote,
“This is one small step for a man, one giant
leap for mankind” already looping through
his head.
Then when he steps off the craft, there are
already several people on the lunar surface,
lounging on deck chairs and asking him if
he’d like a beer.
When he asks them what the hell is going on,
they tell him they just got here an hour ago
and were making themselves comfortable.
Yahweh was beginning to realize that perhaps
he really didn’t hold the sway he thought
he did.
Any bible fans in our audience will know that
the plan for the Christian apocalypse is laid
out pretty clearly in the Book of Revelations
- Satan, armies of angels, giant scorpion
locusts, and in the end, the rebirth of paradise
on earth.
Yahweh thought, all things considered, his
version of the end of everything actually
shook out pretty well for everybody, a little
temporary Hell On Earth and painful damnation
aside.
But here, he wasn’t the Holy of Holies,
he was just one guy with a big-picture idea,
alongside so many other beings, each with
their own big-picture designs for ending things.
All except Asherah.
She’d spent time in a mortal form on Earth
and had really grown to like the place in
that time.
So much so that she didn’t want to see it
end in any manner - In her own words, to a
baffled and somewhat offended Yahweh:
“I may have been called here, but not even
that Lock can make me end the world.
Have you ever tried the seafood in Singapore?
Have you ever used a smartphone?
Ran through the jungle?
Seen Cirque du Soleil?
Flown on an airplane?
Surfed the Internet?
Watched tentacle porn?
Seen Star Wars?
Explored the Wanderer's Library?
Been lost in the concrete mazes of the new
human cities?
No, I like the world the way it is, thanks.
It may be messed up, but tearing it apart
isn't going to improve anything.
So no, I don't plan to end the world.
I actually don't plan to let you end the world
either, or anyone else.
Sorry.”
Yahweh was somewhere between enraged and amazed.
His former consort was not only willing to
go against him but every cosmic being here.
She was staring down the barrel of quite literally
infinite power, and yet, she still stood in
defiance of them.
Yahweh was about to retort when something
even more bizarre happened in the Valley of
Gods and Monsters.
A woman’s voice rang out, simply saying,
“Pardon me”, in a calm, even tone, that
somehow caught the attention of every deity
and world-ender in the valley.
They turned in amazement to see a human woman
in a grey suit, standing among them.
A face that, somehow, all these supposedly
all-knowing beings couldn’t seem to recognize.
But if you SCP Explained fans have been perceptive
in the previous videos, it’s a face you’ll
know all too well: The Administrator.
Never shifting her tone or raising her voice,
she said:
“I come on behalf of the SCP Foundation.
Some of you know who we are.
Some of you do not.
The Foundation are the protectors of humanity.
Some of you we have imprisoned, some of you
we have bargained with, all in defense of
humanity.
I have come to talk.”
Some of the entities laughed.
Others sneered.
Was this woman really arrogant enough to believe
that humans had a seat at this table?
No, their place was resting on the plates,
subject to the mercy of teeth and silverware,
not conversation.
They asked her what she wanted, more out of
morbid curiosity than any real desire to know.
She replied:
“We can open the way to worlds free of sentient
life.
Many worlds.
Enough room for all of you.
You won't have to end this world.
No humans will have to die.
You will have a hundred others.
I want you to let this world live out the
rest of its history in peace.
And in return for this...We will not destroy
you.”
Some laughed.
Others chided.
Most just remained in silence.
When none accepted The Administrator’s offer,
she simply shrugged, and calmly delivered
what seemed less like a threat, and more like
an ironclad promise to the Valley of Gods
and Monsters.
“We are the Foundation.
We will not worship you.
We will not join you.
We will not go back to hiding in fear of you.
I hope you will change your minds, but we
will stand against you, and alone, if we have
to.
All of you.”
And for a fleeting moment, before The Administrator
vanished, Yahweh thought of Himself as SCP-343.
Then...She was gone.
At that moment, the war for the fate of Planet
Earth had truly begun.
Now go check out “Children of SCP-001 The
Scarlet King - Is SCP-999 Really His Son?”
and “SCP-001 Ouroboros Cycle - The Full
Story Compilation” for more of the universe-shattering
implications of SCP-001!